[Music]
who are they I don't
know I followed you no one followed me
Ren what do you want the ark it's what
they're after
what's it do you don't know what you're
doing no no no no
[Music]
no today it's
repeating no tell me you remember but
you have to remember have you lost your
mind you don't have to believe me but I
need you to trust me
Hanah they shot you you
remember is this stream how is this
happening I think the ark is causing
time to Loop how I don't know you're not
telling me something you're crazy
doesn't mean I'm
wrong this can't be
happening head
up
visit my husband you mean your
ex-husband it's my understanding that
the woman who has gone missing was his
Nanny Rael